okay so uh today a topic of the
class uh is uh
carpool's mastery middle game
and um we're gonna see two maybe maybe
three games probably
only two however
and because they're complex enough and
uh complicated enough
that they're you know
and i think it will be enough to uh
say only these two i don't think we'll
have time for for the third one
however uh both are extremely
interesting and i think
those games uh game of antoine carpenter
were
one one of the one of the okay many
because karpov has such a huge impact on
chess in general
but personally that kind of shaped
me in a way my style and um
kind of uh has really really big impact
on me personally so kind of like i want
to show these two games
because personally i like them a lot and
they're pretty much sort of like a must
must know must know
games um okay uh so
if uh everything
wait just don't check can you guys hear
me okay okay i think you can hear me
okay uh so let's get let's get started
um so the first game i want to talk
about is uh of antony carpo
white versus uh vlastimil uh horde
um pretty old game from 1971 i believe
i think so i'm not entirely sure uh it
doesn't really matter when it was played
uh it matters how karpov uh you know was
playing this game so let's see
e4 c5 uh knight f3
d6 d4 stakes d4
knight xd4 uh knight f6
uh knight c3 e6 at the times uh i think
uh
kerr is chavaning and because the
sicilian engine
was extremely popular nowadays this is a
little bit less popular
mostly because of the engines and stuff
and that you know
find a huge advantage basically you ride
away with white right now in the um
probably many lines but mostly in the
carriers attack and
that's why i think that's this one this
line is not as popular as it was back in
the day
engines change the valuations and you
know normal normal development of chess
that some lines go out of fashion for
some reason
they sometimes come back uh some don't
but you know this is how the theory
develops uh g4
uh you know i think the current attack
is the most challenging uh approach to
chevrolet
system um right now
knight c6 was played and after knight c6
um this move allows pretty much with g5
and this is not uh
you know the best ideal uh you know
solution here to black and
i think theory suggests right now h6 and
this also typically main either
variations for instance if we move back
a little bit let's say here
knife neither of h3 e6 g4
very similar right now right and here
the
best move i think or like one of the
best moves is move h6
so similarly here uh in carriage attack
v3 g4 h6 was uh
supposed to be played and i think this
is the better move because it doesn't
allow it to allow white to quickly push
response on the king side
but okay this is a little bit of you
know about theory here
with this we are not interested too much
about it we are mostly interested how
karpov played this propositional
perspective
so let's see what happens knight c6 g5
97 all normal moves
we shall be free a6
uh f4 h4 was also possible bishop b7
uh rogue g1 one of the typical moves
here in um
[Music]
in this type of idea of rook g1 is
basically to
support pawn on g5 many lines uh very
often we want to play h4 h5 and then
rukun g1 is useful
again uh that's why a ruger one was
played but however it was necessary it
was okay let's
play h4 uh play move queen d2 maybe at
some point prepar uh
g1 as well but um you know which one was
karpov's choice
the and uh right now actually this is
kind of destructive
that uh in both positions white tries
not to develop a queen
from d1 too early
it's clear the poor is clear okay great
um but so uh what i was saying that
queen from d1 usually
um gets doesn't get developed too early
and the idea of that is to meet always
knight xd4 with move queen takes d4
because we'll play the sake in d2 knight
xd4 and then we can play bishop to 84
because if queen d4
you know we're sort of losing a tempo so
uh
that's why white tries to postpone
developing the queen from d1 in order to
in case of
knight xd4 which opens happens quite
often uh to recapture the queen
and you know right now
while black has some choice black has
some uh definitely some choice
uh in this position uh you know because
white is attacking here on the king side
right
you know pawns are already well advanced
uh there is definitely some danger here
on the king side usually the best
strategy to attack
to counter attack on the the attack on
the side of the board
whether it's king side or queen as a
matter is to counter attack in the
center
so this is exactly what the last similar
did in this position he played
afterwards d4
queen dxd4 he played with e5 uh
immediately challenging the the
the opening center turning was pawn on
f4 and getting uh
e5 square for his knight only for his
knight
so 22 has been played uh he takes a four
obviously otherwise if white didn't plug
and take on the f4
uh the save showcase will you play f5
will be simply
totally lost we totally lost that's why
uh he had to
sorry here uh he takes the forehead to
be played uh bishop takes a 495
threatening united three but we can play
simply bishop e2 and bishop b6
so this is uh you know the first
let's say position that in which there
is you know white has really some uh
some choice uh right now uh there is
possibility to play
uh you know knight d5 or long castle
personally i like both karpov decided to
play move 95
and okay in general what happens uh
is that move knight d5 uh you know
installs this knife
on very important knowledge d5 square
and the
bishop takes d5 is pretty much forced at
some point because 95 will be just so
strong
so a white essentially wins can win a
pair of bishops
knight on e5 is also very good but it
doesn't have uh
too many squares to go to because it's
totally controlled by this bishop
on uh e2 which controls those squares so
there's this size that
is not uh is well placed obviously but
doesn't have is pretty much
for now uh well controlled so um that's
why uh
you know in this position 95 was played
we know just winning the pair of bishops
and seizing some space because after
bishop 95 bishop takes d5
we take the pawn we don't take the queen
however it was also possible
but the queen if i would be let's say a
little bit less clear because uh
okay also advantages to white but a
little bit less clear because
um you know maybe some d5 would be
kicked out let's say rook c65 idea the
future queen b6 would
be played possible um of course it's
playable
of course possible as well however it
takes d5 i think is
simply better we are gaining space
if this bishop lc would be let's say you
place on g7 this project will be pretty
unclear but visually 7 is pretty much
unfortunately
located and you know white has very
simple plan right now just h4 long
castle
h5 and just attack on the king side and
you know this problem his position is
with black king if it
stays in the center clearly will be you
know in trouble
if it goes to the queen side um and
unlikely will be saved there because
there are only two pawns c files opened
and you know there are ideas maybe luigi
friedrich
see free always you know maybe be free
things like that
and you know it's definitely will be um
king will be in danger if king goes to
uh king's side
also just runs into this attack with on
the
h4h5 and so on so in this position black
somehow has to
uh that can't just wait passively and
you know just do whatever uh and just
you know wait possibly for whatever
white does because then the game will be
just uh you know
being a position become will deteriorate
very very quickly
so here um regardless of what engines
are suggesting because
according to engines what is already
nearly winning but
you know during the game we don't know
that and uh both positions are very
complex in general
so uh in the game for knight g6 which is
very logical move we're trying to
get back the pair of bishops bishop f4
and now uh horde played interesting move
h6
idea of h6 is uh essentially to
you know challenge the pawns on the
queen side
king side before castling the king to
the king's side and still actually
debating where where the king will go
it's pretty much the only moment
whenever black could do that
because uh other if white can go long
castle
the game will be just over right but
right now there's only one
one he could do that because uh if gta
is h6 then bishop h4
and basically white king will stay in
the center
while um you know maybe black will have
one maybe black will have some counter
play
you know against this white king
so uh here in this position uh karpov
decided to take on h6 however according
to my analysis
uh h4 was much stronger so
uh not criticizing karpov at all here by
for his move uh
just kind of like
it's i think instructive to bring it up
right now that h4
such move just giving away this h4h
pawn for for for nothing seemingly is
actually super strong and the reason for
that is that
basically while goes long castle next
move and why has huge
huge attack and it's pretty much
impossible to stop this for instance
analyze
uh okay if h35 of course s3 g5 you know
just you know
position is pretty much hopeless uh
strategically you know the skin can know
where
you can as i discussed earlier unlikely
with the queen side
i like it we stay in the center also
king side is right now out of question
and because of such a bad king position
simply very bad
if knight takes h4 right now uh we can
take
on h6 and bishop there is no bishop h4
check and we go
uh long castle next and the game is just
you know very very uh i mean it's pretty
much decided nearly
if right now simply g6 we can go a long
castle
and uh six let's say which g4 nano h4 is
also out of
out of play and uh yeah this person is
simply you know
bad for black that's why uh here uh
knight f5 was uh maybe a little bit
better but anyway
uh bishop h4 king d1 right now this is
much better version will happen in the
game
and why because some white simply wins
bishop d3 and the game is over
but anyway gtx h6 in this position also
is very good
we show h4 and uh king d1
takes h6 right now we will simply win
the pawn so
there can be nothing be wrong with
getting a pawn right and that's true
there is nothing wrong with it either
white also has big advantage here uh but
things
are not entirely clear in the game
follow bishop f6
and now uh c3 and
right now black plays in bishop e5 so uh
here is the
position uh that i wanted to give you uh
to let's say think about a little bit
and uh if you have suggestions what to
do here with white
you can uh you know saying chat if you
feel like you are confident you that you
have solution
what to do here with white that's very
pretty much critical position
um
first of all i would like if i give i'm
supposed to give you some hint
ask yourself what does black want what
does black want and then
use some prophylaxis
okay here you see some suggestions uh
there is a suggestion of
queenie free bishop g5 and h4 okay
mission to d3 castle uh you cannot
castle
uh marmolejo records uh because
you will remove your kink so you cannot
castle anymore
um so queen e3 let's discuss
uh queen e3 after queen e3
i think there'll be black will be doing
quite well after with queen h4
and because i'm hitting pawn uh sorry
pawn h2 and bishop on h6
hold on a second
cause
um i want to take our pawns so we will
be winning after
the groggy one
okay um
bishop d3 uh black one staggered pawn
will be swimming after removing
one um
okay so basically bishop d bishop d3
also is a good move
but again uh after we should differ i
think i will even sacrifice pawn
here and i'll maybe play queen h4 or
something like this
um that's after bishop d3 maybe queen h4
bishop takes g6 and this this is not
possible because queen h5
right so uh
so this is unclear um bishop g5 is i
think the pre
pro you know predominant right now
suggestion
it's a good move of course
uh also r1 there were suggestions there
was a
suggestion but again after this i go
queen h4 so here you can already see
that
no matter what you do almost i go queen
h4 so i have to somehow stop this so
visual g5 is a logical move
after qh4 though sorry bishop g5 though
i will play uh move queen b6 i think
or uh maybe even bishop f6 why not
bishop f6
let's say such trade will be definitely
in my favor right now
and because then i install mine on e5
and with other square bishops
uh this position is i think very very uh
good for black because you know i will
have
you know very strong e5
and it is not so clear i think unless
i'm missing something but
uh trade four of those which was
definitely in black's favor
so there's bishop g5 also not the best
move
uh
okay any other suggestions
pawn okay so let's look couldn't you
free uh
well first of all you are up upon
already and um
let's say okay i don't see what you mean
like i will go
for instance um
okay actually i got your point right now
because if i play a rogue h7 bishop
takes e5 knight takes e5
g8 you will have okay fair enough um
however okay one thing that immediately
catches my attention right now i can
sacrifice an exchange and i have very
strong blockade only on dark squares
here also it's possible every position
is entirely clear
um another thing like what i can do is
maybe just play rook h7 or with g8 and
uh zero gauge seven
which should be 85 d takes e5 which i
don't really want that but
still maybe it's not so clear uh it is i
guess possible it's not the best
i would say but yeah finally suggestion
of
rook g4 yes rook g4 is by far the best
move
rook g4 uh basically
rugen g4 is very powerful
place very powerfully because uh not
only it
right now uh looks towards the uh king
side where basically
it's prophylaxis against move queen h4
always you know this queen doesn't get
activated to h4
and we control also remove squares like
f4 you know there is never like
anything connected with you know blue hd
maybe some b4 or something like this
um you know we just defended
you know those two squares and but also
we are
looking with our rook towards the queen
side so but it's basically whenever the
skin let's say we'll go to the queen
side or something we our root will be
ready to join the game on the queen side
and you know put some pressure against
black king
so rouge g4 was the was the best
move here and this is what karpov played
i think this is one of the
moves that you know kind of shaped me
because the idea of swinging a rook back
and forth uh or like another back and
forth but you're just placing the rule
there
the possibility of swinging the back and
forth on the fourth rank
uh or like fifth rank if you play with
black or some or even
white you know it's very very
interesting and
it kind of like ever since i saw this
first time
i remember that in many many games i
wanted to sort of employ this idea at
least
or like if i had the possibility to use
it i was generally
trying to make this work so uh very
instructive i think
and uh yeah rook g4 was is very very
strong
so in the game followed right now uh
queen f6 also
makes perfect sense to play with queen
f6 important to one important detail to
know that if bishop takes h2 it simply
doesn't work
because after bishop h2 we are just in
time to play move king c2 and bring our
rook to the game
and uh you know this pawn relationship
is totally relevant we're just totally
irrelevant we just bring this
king to the safety of king c2 sort of
artificial castling
and uh bring the bring the root of say
to f1 or somewhere it doesn't really
matter where
and yeah the game is just just over
because uh after a move like bishop e5
back it
does look f1
[Music]
queen d7 uh and let's say queen e3 and
basically this king
you know is in huge trouble as again
they cannot go to the king side
ever because first of all it's not legal
but secondly
you know even if it was legal you know
would be under huge attack on the kings
side
when the queen side is unlikely an
option uh because after a long castle is
ideal of queen a7
and basically comes to c4 and boy has
winning attack
and that's why uh if the other the king
stays in the center
king will be extremely exposed as well
so uh in this position after queen e3
the game position the position simply
very bad for white
for black i mean that's why taking on h2
uh is a weight essentially of a two
tempi
because uh in such um you know
um put it a dynamic position
like this one you know why white has
extra pawn but
black has some maybe compensation looks
for compensation
you know kings are you know are in the
center so
there is some dynamics here therefore in
this position black sample sort of has
to look for
active counterplay you can just you know
grab the pawn and waste to 10 p
and chill you know it's not possible we
have to look for counter play so
here lassie her play very strong with
queen f6 it was the best uh the things
of in defensive move
idea of queen f6 what is the idea of
queen f6 uh can you guys
what do you think
oh sorry not h3 uh what is it what is
the
queen f6 or what do you want what does
black want here
long castle no long castle is not a
not not the correct idea
um i belie i think that king so far
is pretty safe unlike in the center even
though of course not is perfectly safe
but still it's safer than anywhere else
queen of 500 correct queen f5 is the
idea
bring queen f5 and basically stop uh you
know ask
if possible to you know put some
pressure here on this king let's say if
king c2 queen f5 will be definitely an
idea here
and you know make sure that this king
you know is under some pressure here
white is under some pressure
and right now
uh white play move h4
a very good move basically harassing
this knight from g6
and
right now uh
yes he'll stop king c2 correct basically
if king c2
queen f5 would basically be kind of
annoying
because you know you cannot just defend
on d3 like if queen d3 you're leaving
your bushman
on h6 is unpro undefended and bishop d3
queen g4 right so we have to go like in
befriend king comes
a little bit you know uh shaky and
also uh
well perhaps it was still you know but
it was still possibility
but uh you know uh like at least i can
play move like
maybe queen h5 i try this bishop maybe
take on pawn h2
you know this king is not as safe as it
would be and um
yeah i also can go maybe long castle or
something like that right now because
it's not already hanging
bishop g5 so uh
in the game of h4 ready of h5 and now
queen f5
following the plan and right now uh
let's i wanted to discuss uh why can i
can be taken because uh bishop g7 or
bishop g5 i think both win
i think bishop g7 is the main reason but
bishop g5 also
seems to be winning the episode g5
actually is actually easier because
after queen f2 i go bishop b5
and after it takes i i take quintex f2
uh so oh sorry didn't mean to click that
hold on a second uh
oh boy okay um h4
so queen f5 uh that's why uh right now
and okay in this position so
uh in this position after queen f5 um
it is not so easy for white to make
progress and here uh karpov came up with
a brilliant idea
um but it's brilliant a brilliant idea
that
made history sort of but then the world
objectively doesn't really work
um according to my analysis at least and
it was i think missed by some
commentators and stuff
um but nonetheless this idea here for
white is kind of like historical and
i think it's still a lot too there is
still a lot to learn from it in this
position uh
karpov play move uh roop to b4
and idea of swinging the rook back and
forth right now
on the on the fourth rank is very very
very nice
and you know the point is that right now
long castle is not possible because
bishop g4
obviously however
and okay pawn b7 is attacked so let's
say white plays move blacklight move
like b5 or something like this
then a4 would follow for instance and
the game
the opening the queen side this king
blacking will never find
safety anywhere but there is one
move very much computer move uh
you know that saves the save the day
here for black
can you find the move
can you find the move for black in this
position
it is very difficult it is very
difficult i don't know if i myself would
have
you know come up with this uh when i
would be facing this position uh
at least maybe not like in blitz game or
like rapid game but maybe in classical
game i would
because just really really difficult to
basically even understand what's going
on
but anyway let's see what can you do
can you play like stockfish
hi mj 43 am wow
i'm glad you're here though if it's so
early in the morning
we have black stern right now and uh
what is the best move for black
knight f4 neither far i was simply gonna
take it right take only four this was
the is
exactly the idea of having my rook on on
the fourth rank that basically i cover a
fourth square
i cover a foursquare i can't play
another four or anything to f4
uh rook b8 queen h3
ruby is extremely passive quit h3
if queen h3 whatever are you counter
attacking
what are your counter attacking here if
queen h3 okay queen each one is just one
thread but i'll play queen uh queen king
c2
finally you know bring my king to safety
and play you know rook somewhere and uh
that's it pretty much a queen f5 right
now if you go by now i have bishop d3 my
rogue is
not attacked here on g4 as it was so
this is not
quite not good rugby is extremely
passive as well
rook h6 and taking some and then
something to f4 bishop overnight um
definitely tempting but i don't think
the the it works because
i don't know rook h6 okay let's analyze
rook h6 queen h6 i know
what happens uh like okay knight f4
or bishop f4 um
okay let's save knight f4 i don't know
what is the
kind of like the idea of this move maybe
that takes e2 or something but
um i don't know seems like there's no
immediate threat like fred threat so if
i can just play queen g5 i
offer the queen to trade queens and the
game is just over i guess
uh you don't have anything here any
conversation if bishop f4
then i can just bring my queen back to
h5 even and i cover
everything and i uh and i win uh
so um you cannot just give the exchange
as well
you won't bishop before but again uh
you do we want it here or we wanted
earlier
after we have through h6
a long castle runs into idea of bishop
g4 guys
as i said that earlier again see this
powerful rook
carpools rook on before rook is
operating both kings and queenside
that's the idea here that i wanted to
show in this game
the string of this rook here on the on
the fourth frame long castle is not an
option right now
because of this ruben before now bishop
g4 simply wins the queen
right
okay i guess it's a little bit difficult
uh
so i'm gonna show bishop f6 uh
this is what happened in the game and
this is also not not a good move
this is not also not a good move so
let's see what happened actually
okay you know gold guys let's see what
happened the game and we're gonna go
back to this position and we're gonna
discuss what could have been better okay
so bishop f6 and then now uh white plays
uh
playing with h5 h after h5 uh basically
uh white has a
huge advantage uh this was the moment
where basically horde made a mistake
with bishop f6
okay the find the correct move was very
difficult i will get back there in a
second
uh but okay let's see what happens i
right now we should have six h5
challenging the knight from uh
e7 is from g6 now that goes to e7
to uh attack the knight on the pawn on
d5
and uh with the bomb being attacked
there okay
the 95 isn't possible because simply
rook f4 and basically
uh there's no way to get out of this
spin and
white wins the bishop on f6 so
uh or the queen so 97 had to be played
attacking pawn on d5
and uh okay and what what about now what
will
would you play right now with white find
the best move for white
play like carpool
white to play not black play but white
to play
routine without a call queen f4 uh queen
f4
uh would trade queens and essentially
you're just losing all the advantage
root 87 seems like a free pawn but is it
we should be free queen h5 is a blunder
so let's see after rook takes b7 uh
i think position can get extremely
complicated
rook h because after let's say rook h6
uh you know if queen h6 queen d5 had to
you know
take on d7 b7 i mean so um
i don't know it's becoming really messy
like if this you know queen takes d5
i'll hit here right
so this becomes really really uh
problematic
you can get out of control it's not
really a free pawn
black has hero huge counter play uh
i don't think black is worse anymore
also i can take knight takes d5 but i
don't want to take a rough time h6 but i
think if i also think it's fine
and if there looks if i can play with g8
and go for sorry
go for this
so uh also it's becoming really messy
this position is very complicated
but here uh karpov okay some other
solutions bishop g4
you know usually for queen takes d5 i
guess is fine
yes after rook b7 queen d5 rook 87 will
win the queen
but the thing is i take on h6 first for
instance
uh c4 uh stop
to stop any st4 stop and in b5 look if
you play c4
your rook is suddenly not doing anything
on the
king side is not operating on the king
side only opera is in the queen side
right now is the
range is very limited with pawn c3 it
operates you know
like this so it's much better to have
bigger range for this rook
okay this move is also pretty difficult
so i'm gonna just show it because i have
to go into the lecture right because i
prefer another game of karpov so let's
see what happened
rook to f4 rook swings back to the king
side right now i think it's just
remarkable uh you know to you know to
for the root to operate like that on the
fourth rank and that's why it impressed
me a lot
as a kid and ever since i loved this
game pretty much
um rook f4
uh queen queen e5 hitting hitting the
queen when some queen has to go back
and right now uh karpov made a mistake
uh he played move rook f3
and right now this uh rook goes back
right now to f3 and right now also to go
from this side and the point is uh it's
it's a mistake uh you know because of
pure tactics
and you know playing expression is very
complicated enough so it's hard to judge
a karpov for removal free here um
you know he played you know so far a
remarkable game
and right now the best move was simply
rook f2
the point is you know king has to go to
c2 and bring the to the
you know to e1 or f1 or something and
basically white
has huge advantage and pretty much
nearly winning position
and the difference is between ruger iii
and rook f2 and after uh
rook f3 um you know after let's say
long castle king c2 basically white wins
because rook is protecting bishop on e2
and after rook f3
that's the big difference after
bluegreen long castle this wouldn't be a
case
because right after kings 2 there is
rook takes h6
and that's why uh this is uh you know
not not good
because queen h2 of course queen e2 and
black wins so uh
therefore rook f2 was very important
moved here by karpov
that he missed but uh okay you know even
best
make mistakes nonetheless the game is a
lot to learn from it as positional is a
mastery in my opinion
uh he played ruger free idea of agree
three but right now
again only chance to say the game was
long castle still white is uh
you know probably better but it's
already not so clear
and but right now uh you know uh chord
playing knight takes d5
stopping ruby three similarly what can
be wrong taking the pawn on uh c
on d5 right now right but right now what
okay
right now play simply rook d3 so here i
want to show this maneuver
of the rook let's see how this will
operate again rook for g1
rook g4 rook b4 rook f4 back
ruger freeback rook d3 it's a
it's remarkable in my opinion like how
does look operate in this game
uh extremely rare but uh very nice
overall with there was some you know
room for improvement maybe correct but
uh it's anyway i think a lot to learn
from from this
from this idea after rook d3 basically
the game is just
nearly over nearly over because
you know the identifies hanging and if
the knight goes back you know bishop f4
can follow let's say let's say
this let's say bishop f4 is you know for
example very strong pawn on d6 is just
collapsing so in the game for rook takes
h6 trying to look for a
contour play and if queen takes h6
then bishop g5 suddenly could be you
know extremely
complicated suddenly you know knight e3
comes into play and there is some
counterplay for for black
and we don't want that karpov of course
never allows something like this
uh simply rook takes d5 so under move
with the rook
but you know it's it's just winning
because right now
strategically white is totally winning
position not tactically but
strategically no longer material but you
know
much better uh you know pieces
and safer king which is the which is the
most important thing
uh why did you play knights if it was
dangerous yes it does look dangerous but
you know uh
it's a difficult position to play and
the you know the only move
is essentially here in long castle it's
very difficult to find any way
uh i mean it's already when you look for
it but maybe
he miscalculates something or i don't
know you know it's uh
um maybe he even hims calculates
something with black
but we we wouldn't worry about it
because we are interested
we you know what i'm trying to say is
at the for the purpose of carpools let's
say play
at mother's little even though it was a
best you know saving move
still ideas of this rook swinging back
and forth
uh is which is the main theme of this
game uh
you know it doesn't is irrelevant for
that reason
um
yeah maybe he was afraid of some rookie
three or something i don't know
uh doesn't matter uh after root is five
by white simply wins queen e4
uh rook d3 back and finally king goes to
c2 bishop has to have three rook comes
to e1 the game is just over
so um queen h1
king c2 we can give the a1 rook because
we are getting the h6 rook
and um right now you can you guys can
see that
the black king is totally exposed has no
way
there's no way he can be defended bishop
g5 queen g5
very nice five wonder you know for two
final two moves because right now
this king would have let's say either
they want to go long castle
but queen g5 stops this so uh
right now give king to follow king seven
trying to bring the rook but of course
it runs into queen e5
and here uh um
here of course white uh you know win
white one black i think resigned here
yes white black resigned
so let's see let's go back right now uh
anyway not very nice maneuvering of the
rook
so that's the point but let's go back to
the position
here that i want to talk about
after uh
[Music]
rook b4 so in the game of bishop f6 h597
and now look at f4 right so
uh and because of brook f4
this simply wins forward
so in this position the best move for
black
i know i'll just show it because we have
to go to the next game
right now that i prepared and the best
one for black was knight e7
and position it gets extremely
complicated the pain defined the point
is i mean
that uh rook cannot go to f4 right now
bishop 25 this is simply covered right
and
we don't care about spawn b7
we care about king not white king not
getting into safety
and creating some conditions knight from
e7 a
in many lines attacks pawn d5 which is a
possibility
and here after let's say rook takes b7
the best move for white is to play very
strong move queen e4
retaining the you know the pressure on
this diagonal not allowing the king go
to c2
threatening queen h1 threatening knight
f5 ready knight d5 suddenly queen is so
swell centralized here
and potions totally are clear analyze a
little bit like
one let's say following lines or would
have happened c4 let's say queen h1 king
c2 queen a1
and uh you know black wins the rook
but white has let's say strong attack
after queen g5
so but again black can defend with like
knight takes d5 stays d5 rook c8
for counter attacking the here i missed
this yeah uh
sorry um knight is five no cd is
impossible because
it's basically very strong counter
attack essentially winning under attack
but white can go bishop h5 or something
like this attacking point f7
position is total mess just totalness
absolute absolutely unclear position
this afternoon
like b4 this queen f1 something like
this
i analyzed and this is just completely
unclear
uh this was basic but you guys can see
that this is all computer analysis
this is this never happened in the game
it had small likelihood
happening in the game it was just so
complicated and that's push is pretty
much crazy yes
okay uh so but anyway the idea here i
will show back again to this idea
of um okay and okay one more one thing i
want to say about this game
34 queen f5 ruby 4 was the mistake for
the reason of 97
the best one was simply between a4 maybe
play then a5 and maybe another rook and
sometimes you come to a four
seeing space on the queen side rule
before retaining we
retain this idea and white is better was
clearly better but it's far from winning
as long as those pieces
black piece especially the king you know
is unsafe um you know
black black will be struggling and long
castle is always possible but always
runs into some ideas on the king's side
on the queen side because
king will be exposed there as well so
that's why um
[Music]
you know you have rook g4 and then but
nonetheless regarding
g4 before swinging rook back and forth
then to f4 and f3
e3 d3 and so on it's very instructive my
opinion
okay uh so uh that's this game
i would i want to show next let's go
let's go to the next one i prepared we
don't have much time for this game
however there were some few instructive
modes i wanted to share with you guys
from the next game karpov's game so
let's go
let's get to it
um if so next game is between uh android
karpov and uh vasilis is
boris and the game followed e4 again
uh against italian e6 d4
and xd4 knight xd4 knight f6 knight c3
d6 in the previous game uh cardboard
chose g4
this time he chose let's say a little
bit more positional approach which is
bishop e2
uh bishop e7 short castle short casual
f4 knight c6 bishop e3
bishop d7 and here uh you know the idea
of bishop d7 is basically to play knight
takes d4
uh and followed by bishop c6 that's why
in this position
white generally plays move knight b
whenever white black plays bishop d7
white generally plays knight b3 removing
this knight from uh from the center and
making sure this bishop doesn't come to
c6 comfortably
that's why um
that's why in this position white uh
you know removes the knight to make this
bishop uncomfortable on d7
in many lines black plays bishop's head
voluntarily for instance there was
classical game
um carp of kasparov from the world
championship match
whenever uh you know a similar position
and you know when
mag karpov began attacking g4 g5
then let's say after move like a6 a4 or
something let's say
queen seven maybe on a bishop f3 b6 for
instance i think it's theory composition
and now g4 followed by g5 right now the
best move is play bishop cag 597
so that's why we sort of tried to win a
tempo for for you know
for this move knight b3 because bishop
has misplaced uh and now it has to go
back
because it's misplaced we can leave the
sub square for the night
so that's the general idea uh of white
however in this game something like this
happened and you know knight b3
is a good move for the reasons i i
explained
and right now uh a5 happened
in the game which is also very logical
trying to play a4 change design on b3
however a5 has this drawback that we can
significantly all the squares on the
i mean b5 square on the queen side and
right now
uh a4 followed and the idea
is to uh make use of this b5 score maybe
949 b5 maybe bishop b5
and so on so uh the game for rhino
knight before bishop f3
all normal stuff and here in this
position um
black played move uh inaccurate move
bishop c6
the better move was e5 and this is
typical let's say
the game this game will also play a long
time ago 1970s
and uh you know now modern theory such
as e5
uh it's a typical israeli positions idea
of rookie we should be sick so you can
meet this idea very often either we can
meet this idea very often in
rouser and yeah this is pretty much what
black should do in this for
these type of positions bishop c6
seemingly logical because beauty 756
finally bishop rich is his destination
but
it is simply not good because right now
knight after knight d4
if e5 ever happens trying to kill this
uh knight from
d4 then knight f5 will follow that's
after e5
and the 5 will be very very strong so
that's why in this position with basket
play move g6
and after g6 rook f2 very nice idea of
playing rook d2 and knight b5
to attack pawn on d6 and now e5 so here
is the question here is the
first question for you guys well would
you play here with white
the question is pretty much would you
play uh knight xb5 sorry knight xc6 or
knight db5
because we our knight is under attack
obviously right so we have to move
our knight somewhere either we uh go
with it with perfect square on b5 or
maybe we can
uh trade the for it for it for trade for
the bishop
so those are those will be the two moves
that i would consider at first
knight e2 is also possible as very
passive usually making you when you go
active use where to go active so that's
why it
can simplify your choice what was better
knight db5 or knight xc6
okay uh so mostly i think uh you guys
say knight b5 i think no one suggests an
attack's the
uh bishop a knight is bishop just have
somebody's basket spawn structure in
center
so here is the thing uh
karpov played knight takes c6
both moves leads to advantage but knight
succeeds is much stronger
it's a revolutionary i think at the time
idea here
and the point is uh we'll see the point
in a moment
but after knight takes five nine knight
db5 awkward it's also possible
but so far politics is well guarded and
uh maybe
you know black would place this this
maybe something like something like d5
or something at some point i don't know
becoming
sorry number 35 d5 i'm becoming a little
bit messy
rogue f2 always runs with some queen b6
checks so
it's not so clear either and um
you know in this position uh i think
this is not entirely clear however
knight takes c6
is a very strong move it seemingly uh
improves the
sponsor spassky's pawn structure in the
center but
in reality it doesn't first of all the
united states of course this position is
bad right now uh
you know it's similar to whatever would
have happened after not turning down b5
bishop c5 which is obviously horrible
right that takes b5 is big advantage for
white so uh
black cannot take with the knight on c6
bc
has to be played but right now uh we can
play f takes e5
d takes e5 and right now uh look if we
look at this position
black has three pawn islands one uh one
two and three and
especially on the okay so so what so so
does white however the most important
thing to realize that without light
square bishop
and the design on this this last
question all the light squares are
extremely weak
and we have light square bishop
especially c4 square becomes a really a
problem right now
and on additionally an item before
seemingly very strong right
it is in reality not a no no no not so
strong
the point is that even though we attack
on c2 we are well guarded
there by the rook and we can just
isolate this now we can just
completely ignore it and uh we have we
will have some advantage because nylon
before apart from attacking c2 doesn't
do absolutely anything
right that's why uh white is better and
while right now we do not trade queen
playing with queen f1 that's what
carpool did very strong move basically
maybe preparing getting uh queen to c4
or maybe
even bishop to c4 if if possible so
uh right now makes sense for black to
put the queen save with idea of knight
g4
of course karpov plays prophylaxis he
plays h3 doesn't allow this
and right now black should try somehow
to get those bishops of the board
if black can get positions off the board
um
you know and then control dark squares
[ __ ] will be
pretty much balanced and i think black
will have some counter play
this is not uh you know as we will see
this never had a chance of
occurring so right now in the game for
knight d7 a value of bishop c5 this is
which is very logical
alternative would have been queen b7 and
and uh right now the one perfect perfect
plan would be let's say knight d2 and uh
knight 182 knight c4
which is possible but there's also a
alternative uh
i'll get to this point in a second uh
however uh alternative of
rook c14 by bishop e2 bishop c4 is even
better basically hitting a design on f6
as well
and the white has a big advantage as
well because again we are isolating this
diamond before
we bring idea of brooks translation b2
because we need to over protect
the pawn c2 to get this you know bishop
to c4 square
and white is by our phrases after king
g7 which should be two knight e8 we have
c4 knight g6
just rook d1 and this this also again
designs totally isolate on the queen
side
it's not
getting to the game anytime soon so
in the game for 97 ideal bishop c5 to do
it immediately queen c4 would have been
a little bit awkward maybe maybe queen
ac would have followed
but right now bishop g4 will come from
this side and
basically we are happy to trade this
bishop for this knight
we are the we don't mind it as long as
we keep those bishops large scriptures
on the board
and we play against dino before and this
is what capo exactly was doing
h5 bishop takes d7 uh rook takes d7
and now queen c4 without the knights
without the queen you know getting to a6
we can install our queen on c4 there's
nothing wrong with that
so bishop h4 uh four kids so i'm trying
to chase this rook away
uh rook d2 queen e7 idea maybe
um i know bishop g5 maybe at some point
uh
but okay rook f1 put some pressure on
the f5 so
maybe he could have bishop g5 but it'll
be anyway risky because after even takes
takes rook f2
uh pressure on the f will be very very
annoying perhaps uh
also after bishop g5 there's bishop c5
that has to be considered
anyway no matter what happens no matter
what black does
the white is always much better because
of this hormone before
so after rook fd8
yeah basically um
what would you play here with white what
would you play here with white
white to play in this position
why would you uh give a blight score
bishop when you have light scores and
control
in order to give black control over the
dark squares because if we never
if we never did that then bishop c5
black would have played and tried the
light dark square bishops and black
would control the
uh dark squares okay
that's why uh we and we anyway control
right now light square is our queen on
c4
we still have a very nice control over
light squares
but most importantly is like prophylaxis
against what black can do
bishop c5 okay possible
there are many moves that give to
advantage rook e2 also
interesting rook taste d8
also possible
voss moves the usages are possible but
they are not the best move
play like carpool i cannot do that
knight b1 knight a2 now his eye is too
strong
on the contrary it's like he's not it's
totally uh
out of out of play it doesn't do
anything
not before it's horrible night it
doesn't it's nicely placed seemingly at
first but it doesn't has no
no function totally has no function and
training those knights
helps black a lot that's why the best
movie inspiration is to play knight to
b1
uh our night is our night is not our
knight is about correct
basically this pawn on c6 controllable
squares we can't improve our knight
actively but there so we have to reroute
it in different
direction knight b1 therefore and we go
our knight to c4 square sometimes
sometimes we may go to the king side but
any and also
often we want to play move c3 to chase
his knight away
to make kind of illustrate how bad it is
basically has to
have to go back to a6 right and uh yeah
knight b1 and white has huge advantage
again for queen b7 king h2
king g7 c3 knight a6
and right now a very nice idea
by karpov kind of rare i'm not gonna ask
you what would you play here because
uh um we have to to get going sorry with
the next
the next topic next class sort of which
we're gonna discuss in a moment
um but here very nice idea here by
by karpov rook to e2
he played rook to e2 to basically and he
gives away the control that
over our d file but as we will see in a
second this is totally irrelevant
the default is solely irrelevant what
matters is how badly black pieces are
placed
this knight comes to a free we want to
maybe and then if
this knight bishop is i mean it's out of
h4 we can even double the default is
totally irrelevant
so um after uh
so right now rook avery trying to
overprotect pawn f7 but the game is
right now over
uh yes it is very
um re2 is very difficult move to play
that's why i wasn't asking you also
because
it is very very difficult to play like
this
but it just shows huge understanding by
karpov you know this middle game because
his pieces
he has better pieces so it makes no
sense to trade them especially if you
trade draw on the eighth or something
you are essentially
trading this rook sorry not really two
you're trading this book for oh come on
this look for this rook
and we're gonna it's horrible right so
why would you trade it why would you
even unlock trade those rooks
rookie two keep this regulate horrible
keep it keep it horrible
that's the idea ruger wait followed
trying to maybe
bring rook 88 and protect on f7 somehow
but now the id tonight now that comes to
the game and
the game is okay bishop d8 followed okay
we thought if he was a threat
anyway he's not really saving now with
six he tried to hold it together
but right now look even if he you know
he true you know
retreated from the open file by his
strong moves
or like you know characteristics of the
position there was no better move for
black
right now no one controls the default
and essentially those rooks are
disconnected so right now
he goes back and he controls he now
controls the default and the default
pretty much decides the game
which will be seven queen e6 threatening
rook d7 and the game is just over the
rest of the few moves
are you know uh nice uh i mean
rook takes the e87 was a big threat so
replace d8 now if bishop takes d8
uh we can play just rook d1
and if there is d8 towards knight x e5
as well possible or knight g5 even
uh both moves win um
so bishop d8 followed rook d1 14 rule d7
knight b8 you see this horrible knight
design wasn't before but it was never
even close to doing anything now has to
go back maybe in 199698
and after you know bishop c5 rook ajade
finally retakes the eight um spassky
resigned and um replace the
rib line because it rotates yes bishop
e7 and
put on the board quickly and yeah
basically hitting this hitting this
white simply once simply wins so this
was a very interesting
game uh by karpov as well very nice uh
strategic understanding and uh you know
especially ideas like knight takes c6
taking you know
this pair of bishops coming back let's
say the knight b1 ideas of
e2 are all very difficult and that's why
this is the mastery that i wanted to
show today
a very nice game by karpov and also a
game that
heavily influenced me you know as a
young player
and yeah sorry like a game everyone i
think
should should know okay so this is all i
have for now
about the grand master's choice i'll be
back literally like a minute or two
with the next class on the games of the
week
and well i'm gonna be discussing uh the
final
the highlights because there were eight
there were eight games between magnus
carson and wesley so
i'll basically bring the i think all the
games is
pretty much too time consuming but i'll
bring the highlights uh
of the match and i think it will be very
interesting to see what both players
miss what opportunities they had and uh
and so on
so uh we will i will see you guys then
and for now thank you for watching this
and i'll see you soon